[Musique]
ces images montrent bien la force du
déluge qui s'est abattu sur la commune
de saint joseph au cours du week-end
dernier des rivières en crue et des
torrents d'eau se sont déversés à
vincendo ce mur d'une dizaine de mètres
de long s'est littéralement effondré
laissant le passage libre à l'eau et à
la boue qui se sont engouffrés dans ces
habitations plusieurs familles ont tout
perdu comme wendy payet cela avait de la
terre tour jusqu'à la porte qu'elle est
qu ouvrir les portes en bois les gens
lara que tout pouvoir monter tours les 9
sous bois et l'eau la rentrée dans toute
la maison nature y est même leur ment
l'encan sur pied mais faudra vider
le préfet le sous préfet le président du
département ainsi que les maires de
petites îles de saint joseph et de
saint-philippe se sont rendus sur place
pour constater l'étendue des dégâts tous
se mobilisent comme le département pour
aider les familles nous avons un service
des interventions qui est disponible
mais qui est avec des travailleurs
sociaux qui vont faire une évaluation à
chacune des familles impactés par cette
crise va de justement de ce que nous
pouvons porter nous le faisons en lien
je le dis avec le ccas de la commune de
saint-joseph pense que le travailleurs
sociaux sont là aussi pareil en
coordination avec les services sociaux
de la commune mais d'ores et déjà eh
bien nous avons des dispositifs comme le
shaq d'accompagnement alimentaire
hygiène qui peut être mobilisés je
voudrais aussi dire que quand il ya des
dégâts sur les habitations
autant que faire se peut nous avons
aussi donc un dispositif d'amélioration
de l'habitat qu'on va pouvoir donc
mobilisés pour accompagner ces familles
mais la solidarité départementale elle
s'exerce en lien avec les communes et
bien sûr avec la commune de saint-joseph
ici
les communes les plus impactées comme
saint-joseph et saint-philippe demandent
la reconnaissance de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle et la mobilisation
des fonds de secours outre-mer les
équipes des unités territoriales
routière du sud sont mobilisés depuis
plusieurs jours pour remettre en état
les axes de circulation
dans la journée de samedi on a eu une
arrivée d'eau de la ravine dominique et
qui a qui est passé sur sur la route et
qui emportait tout la chaussée donc on a
fait intervenir les équipes
sam dimanche matin et on a pu réouvrir
là une voie de circulation dimanche
après-midi en fin d'après midi tu te
sauvage a été très touché la petite île
saint joseph on a été justement sur
saint-joseph la région de bézaves
là-haut donc aujourd'hui s'est rétabli
je veux dire il faut féliciter justement
les services routiers du département
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure ils ont
été très réactifs des intempéries qui
montre l'importance du plan radier lancé
par la collectivité qui vise à sécuriser
les radiers submersible une trentaine
ont d'ores et déjà été supprimés sur les
156 recensés
[Musique]